our impairment levels are very low we're
not seeing any signs of of real uh
distress or deterioration um incredible
resilience among households and and
businesses so very low levels of
impairments obviously a lot of
discussion around an activity and
proactive contact with helping people
manage you know cost of living and
higher interest rates and inflation but
in terms of our book very resilient very
robust and and very limited signs of
distress well you have been making
impairments where have they been focused
well they're very limited actually what
we've seen is in in the very low levels
of impairments and they're they're way
below pre-covered level it has been in
in people who've been in distress
previously and and actually in most
instances where we are seeing people
move into what we call heightened
monitoring it's not really cost of
living it will be the impact of the
economy plus a life event that tends to
be where we see people moving into
needing help from our financial health
and support teams so underlying
macroeconomic or sector levels are not
really driving in obviously we're
keeping a close eye on those sectors
that are most impacted by
inflation or consumer spending but we're
really not seeing any sort of
deterioration or Trends coming through
at this point now when we last spoke you
said you thought that uh the bank of
England bank rate would Peak at four
percent what you're thinking now
yeah I mean obviously um there have been
further rate Rises and and the trends
are saying maybe maybe one maybe another
two uh rate Rises coming through I think
um it really depends on where inflation
comes through certainly we we're seeing
um the latest assumptions saying it may
go up to you know an another rate rise
maybe uh maybe two so it really depends
on how quickly inflation comes down no
the net interest margin which of course
is the difference between what you
charge borrowers and pay depositors is
up to 3.27 that actually came in lighter
than uh some in the market was expecting
what were the factors at play there yeah
it came in exactly where we we thought
it would come in um you know that was uh
broadly the the guidance that that we
said and we've given guidance of what it
will be for the year clearly um what
we're balancing is
um you know the interest rate that we
pass through and and the growth on our
book what we've seen in this quarter is
very strong growth in lending 5.7
billion deployed into the economy on a
very balanced way deposits are a little
bit lower in q1 as we expected them to
be it's a period where
um you know there are big tax payments
that come out we're seeing really
rational and sensible Behavior by
consumers in terms of managing some of
their debt and maybe prepaying some
things down and a little bit more
competition coming through so
um but but we're pretty comfortable with
where it's come through uh I I think
people expected us to upgrade but we
remain confident with the guidance that
we've given to the market and it is
early in the year now last year you
raised your share of the mortgage market
and it looks as though you're continuing
to trade above your long-term average
yeah we've seen our um our mortgage
share increase from 15 to 17 in q1 as
you know last year during that period of
real Market volatility and disruption we
made the decision to stay in the market
well a lot of our
um competitors pulled out we thought
that was really important for customers
given the huge uncertainty that's there
and you're seeing some of that flow
through into our market share you know
we're very competitive we're there
supporting our customers doing it
responsibly our average loan to value on
our mortgage book is 53 but we are
seeing good growth and and that's really
what I've talked about with the position
of NatWest we have the capacity to grow
a really resilient and well Diversified
balance sheet which means we're robust
and able to support our customers and
that growth is what you're seeing coming
through in our book now you saw 19.8
billion pounds worth of deposit out
flows during the quarter what was going
on there is is that customers eating
into their long-term savings spending
those savings
well there's a number of things
um going on um obviously uh in q1
January February it's a big uh period
when when tax gets paid and we've seen
you know more people uh caught in the
tax bracket so big tax outflows which
are a normal seasonal flows we have seen
customers proactively paying down some
of their debt a little bit of mortgage
prepayment
um a little bit of you know more
expensive debt being paid down and we
are seeing a little bit of system
liquidity come out where you know people
are using maybe a little bit of that
buffer they built up during covid
um to continue
um spending and absorbing inflation but
but we're generally seeing customers
economizing sensibly and good decisions
happening around their balance sheet so
it's a combination of those three things
of what we're seeing across the market
and more broadly how are you managing
costs in this inflationary environment
we're managing costs in a really
disciplined way
um we've we've given Guidance the week
expect our costs to be around 7.6
billion for the year we've had higher
costs in the first quarter which are
really you know some of the targeted
interventions that we've made to help
with cost of living in terms of one-off
cash payments to staff and also our exit
from
um Ulster Bank which as you know we're
withdrawing from some of costs coming
through strategic costs as we accelerate
that obviously AI is a very very hot
topic right now for for businesses of
all shapes and sizes is that informing
the way that you you look at the
business very much well I think AI
offers you know some interesting
opportunities machine learning
um the element of AI that we use quite a
lot um you know we have Cora our chatbot
which we've had in place for some time
uses machine learning natural language
processing we use robotics a lot now in
terms of some of our customer Journeys
as we we have digital obviously we're
keeping a close eye on some of the
developments around looking into the
future GP T obviously is is something
we're looking at but I think it offers
real opportunity and making sure we're
balancing sort of some of those
Innovations and how they can inform the
future
now your common Equity Tier 1 ratio
which is a measure of how much Capital
you're holding at the moment you set a
long-term Target for that of 14 you're
actually above that now is that money
burning a hole in your pocket
well our guidance is um we're aiming to
be around 13 to 14 that is uh reflective
of the strong risk discipline we have
across the book
um I've been really clear that my
intention is to distribute Capital to
shareholders
um in our 14.4 that we've announced in
q1 it is above guidance it shows the
strong Capital generation in our
business
um which means we're well positioned to
participate if the government decide to
do a directed buyback which we have
permission for and obviously I've I've
already committed to Capital
distributions or any other opportunities
it may present but the good thing is our
business is generating generating
Capital we have really strong franchises
good risk discipline and that gives us
the opportunity to invest and distribute
Capital to shareholders or any other
opportunities that may present
themselves